a lilo brancato i've heard you talk
about him before when he got in trouble
himself because he was a star coming up
at a young age and he didn't know how to
handle a good looking guy he does a
movie like bronx tale he's partying he's
everywhere women are all over him what
happened to him he's out right now i
know he's out but what happened with his
story what happened was he you know he
it was 16 years old i mean it was too
much too soon you know
he believed all the the press reviews
and everything and
he just acted terrible and got involved
with drugs he became a junkie and
and it was funny because as the years
were going on i used to say to him i
said lilo you were in the quintessential
movie about not wasting your life and
that's wasted and it's exactly what
you're doing wow i said do you realize
that you're you're living the movie yeah
what was his response no no i'm gonna be
cool i'm gonna be cool yeah three weeks
before it happened he came to my house
because he wanted me to do a movie write
a movie about this guy and he was stoned
i said lilo it's going to happen sooner
or later three weeks later a big report
on the news that a cop died was shot he
was with the guy and that was it are you
still in touch with him no i don't speak
to him anymore
i tried for 10 years to talk to him and
now
i look he's a talented kid
he could have been a big star
but my friendship is over with him but i
wish him well i i hear he straightened
his life out i think that's great i hear
he helps kids i think that's great and i
wish him well how did you look at him as
a son at some point no no no chaz how
how often does that happen
do you see like not being able to manage
the limelight is there what comes with
the limelight i mean when you get the
lime can okay so for example
you you're doing broad you're doing uh
uh theater right you're doing all this
and great
how many people are in audience by the
way five hundred thousand ten thousand
five thousand
the most 25 3 000. let's say 2500 to 3
000 people there's a big difference
between 2 500 to 3 000 to 50 million
people watching the movie right it's a
big big difference
what happened the moment bronx still
became a hit and you're nominated for
the academy what happens to your life
what happened overnight it was amazing
i was totally
i was totally unknown i was an actor but
i was totally unknown the next minute
i remember we're flying
we're flying to paris
uh i'm on a private jet with bob and
we're flying to paris and
he's sleeping in one bed and i'm
sleeping in the other and i wake up
and i just looked at him sleeping there
i look out the window you know blackness
and
i went wow
here i was like
months before just
and now i'm on a private jet with bobby
nero you know
and i got up i'll never forget it and
there was a guy just sitting there
reading he was like the butler you know
and i said do you have any i was a
little hungry i said do you have any
like um
you know finger food or something like
it i'm a little hungry you know i was
never on a private jet before
and he said well what would you like
that you want some pancakes or french
toast or something
and i was like oh
uh pancakes french toast
i'll make you an omelette you know what
i'm like get some salted peanuts
that's right
he opens up the table he puts the white
table there he puts a rose there on a
thing and like you know such a beautiful
table up i'm sitting there and
he's cooking and he's making me pancakes
and i'm eating scrambled eggs and i'm
looking i'm eating and i look over and
bob is sleeping and i go
all right chaz i go but you belong here
but i said that to myself i said
you belong here it's okay but that was
one that was a moment it's funny you
brought that up patrick that was one of
the first moments that i was like yeah
wow and then we got off the plane in
france
in paris and there was this giant giant
wall
with bob's face and my face looking at
each other it's that posting yeah and i
was like wow pull up the poster right
now that's one of the sickest posters
when you interviewed mike tyson yeah and
he was the world champion and and you
asked the question of just giving me
sort of vibes like this you said
when did you know you would be the
champion and he says uh
what was his response when he was 14
years old you sometimes you have to be
the child you have to you have to
believe you're a champion before you
become a champion there's a lot of
similarities there is that basically how
you knew you would there's there's a
you have to go there in the mine
before you can go there physically
you know
it's like when people train like navy
seals why they train so much
and when they get into the [ __ ] they're
there already because they trained it
yeah they're there so you have to go
there in your mind you know so i always
already pictured myself
working with great people and what age i
saw that mindset started
god i want to be an actor with 10
probably in my you know 11 12 13. so
when you're 38 and that 250 thousand
dollar check comes you're thinking no i
i'm going to hold out the only person
the only person that i ever got star
struck and i worked with all of them the
biggest stars
the only person i could never get over
who he was was frank sinatra wow wow
only one you've been on set with sophia
vergara not star struck even a little
bit sofia she's a beautiful person
what
every time i was with him
i would just kind of just put my head
down and go frank so naturally
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]